frédéric d'abord disons que interpol
l'organisation internationale qui existe
depuis longtemps
oui la première mouture c'était en 1914
avait été fondée à l'époque à monaco
quarante années plus tard on a redéfini
le mandat et on a donné le vrai nom
d'interpol c'est à dire l'organisation
internationale de police criminelle
ça c'était en 1956 le siège social ce
n'est pas à washington ou new york mais
pour l'instant c'est à lyon en france il
se fait une vingtaine d'années que c'est
comme ça deux objectifs primordiaux
c'est combattre la criminalité et faire
une coopération et un échange
d'informations entre les différents
gouvernements et les agences de police
internationale
on a donc une présence ici assez
importante on à 194 pays membres sept
bureaux qui sont répartis sur l'ensemble
du gol du du globe et nous avons un
budget de fonctionnement qui avoisine à
peu près 180 8 millions de dollars c'est
pas énorme et regarder nombre de
personnes qui travaillent pour cette
agence c'est seulement 800 personnes
donc on est loin d'un service de police
par exemple comme celui de new york où
on a d'un budget de plus de 5 milliards
et demi de dollars avec trente quatre
mille cinq cents agents en uniforme
alors et on connaît surtout interpol
pour ces notices le coloré voilà en fait
y en a huit qui vont du rouge jusqu'au
bleus de l'onu rouge c'est probablement
la plus connue c'est lorsqu'on n'en
diffuse en fait les fameux mandats
d'arrêt internationaux qui ont été émis
non pas par interpol mais par les
services de police donc on les recherche
ardemment
il ya aussi la notice jaune cette fois
ci ça concerne les personnes qui ont été
qui sont portées disparues en fait vous
allez voir maintenant trois photos on
l'a ben laden de l olive et des
médicaments c'est quoi le point commun
mais ce sont des dossiers qui sont
passés par interpol d'abord pour
l'arrestation il ya eu un mandat en 2004
contre monsieur ben laden il ya eu
également eu toute une sorte de de dali
mort frelaté ça touchait des milliers de
tonnes en europe d'olive et puis aussi
la contrefaçon de médicaments brille
quand on voit ça ça touche énormément de
sujets de la part d'interpol et bien sûr
les dossiers c'est le terrorisme c'est
le crime organisé est aussi la
cybercriminalité qui prend de plus en
plus de place pour interpol oui mais
est-ce qu'elles passent certains
questionnements sur le fonctionnement
d'interpol mais d'abord sur le
financement on disait tantôt c'est pas
beaucoup d'argent 180
lyon est la difficulté à les chercher de
l'argent auprès des membres donc là on a
ouvert les portes à des capitaux privés
c'est un peu étonnant par exemple philip
morris le cigarettier ya les compagnies
pharmaceutiques ou encore même la fifa
fédération internationale de football
qui met de l'argent là-dedans donc il ya
peut-être des possibles conflits
d'intérêts et l'autre chose aussi à
surveiller c'est que on pense que
certains pays qui sont membres
d'interpol
en fait c'est intéresse à interpol et
investissent pour parfois muselé et
faire arrêter des opposants à certains
régimes dans les gouvernements donc
point d'interrogation un petit peu sur
le fonctionnement de cette police
spéciale et on verra ce qui va se passer
demain cette nomination remercie
beaucoup the black